I've been sticking my neck out for this
lot all along but they keep letting me
down so that goes back in there yeah
where's that time
you at it policy guys I mean you you
make it difficult for me why did you eat
it
we all got with them chips to March who
else is eating the tarts
give me one as well why do you want so
you think stuff in your face is better
than selling you ain't get money in here
to keep you in here
it's the first rule of business don't
eat your profits
I need those orders you've eaten them
you I didn't expect that from you I
didn't expect that from you don't eat
anything every step of the way
it keeps flooding back to me I'm trying
to set up a business with a bunch of
criminals okay
get out of here make those calls please
okay I'll see in the morning these guys
better not let me down the Baker might
be finished but tomorrow
they've got 300 cakes to ice two hours
until the opening the bakery and my bad
boys have got in touch with their
feminine side but there's always one who
has to go too far
lick me who put lick me on a cake you
want someone to lick you jesus christ
almighty let's go where's Joe I think
it'd been suspended for today what
happened you're suspended this morning
where is he now any self on a day like
today no one's even bothered to tell me
they keeping Jerome on the wing
I need to know what's happening with my
own kitchen workers so I'm back on a
wing to see senior officer call
mr. Cole for me is getting more more
difficult the small percent of a bakery
and you know I've got over a thousand
items to sell I walked in this morning
and there's there's no Jiro I can't run
a business in there when you guys are
just pulling people out and I'm none the
wiser um I understand that but we don't
pull them out they pull themselves out
they pull themselves up by their
behavior don't like I've sat down with
him
I've explained to him I've talked to
I've taken these issues on board I've
include the system and helped him so in
a way you writing him off yes sorry you
drop yourself off but I I'm gonna fight
for it because I can't see that behavior
in the kitchen which I think's more of a
dangerous environment when he's around
knives around other individuals and the
discipline when he toes the line he
actually he knocks down that's what you
don't see and that's my frustration but
now I'm a man down a busy day and okay
as far as a wins concerned just amazing
thank you thank you to get
that's where it's so wrong because no is
on basic he's out the course and he
shouldn't be on there in the first place
well how you ever gonna change these
young guys mindset how you ever going to
get into them - he's young enough to be
taught that's the first rating thing
it's not Lawrence Gibbons
you know it's 22 literally
so frustrated so perfect